Alors que je marche dans la vallée de l'
ombre de la mort, je jette un coup d'œil à ma vie
et je réalise qu'il ne reste plus rien parce que
j'ai ri et explosé si longtemps
que
même ma mère pense que mon esprit est parti
mais je n'ai jamais traversé  un homme qui
ne le méritait pas
moi être traité comme un punk tu sais
que c'est du jamais vu
tu ferais mieux de regarder comment tu parles ou
où tu marches ou toi quand ta
maison est mon requin belandant
je déteste vraiment trébucher mais je dois  regarde
pendant qu'ils coassent je me vois dans l'
imbécile de fumée de pistolet je suis le genre de g que les petits potes
veulent être comme sur mes genoux la nuit en
disant des prières dans le réverbère
j'ai passé la plupart de nos vies à vivre dans
le paradis des gangsters
J'ai passé la majeure partie de notre
vie à
vivre dans le paradis des gangsters
[Musique]
Je suis un antéchrist
Je suis une banane
Je ne sais pas ce que je veux mais je sais comment l'
obtenir
Je veux détruire le passant parce que je
[Musique]
Je  Je suis si heureux parce qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai retrouvé mes amis
[Musique]
nous avons brisé nos miroirs s  unday matin
est tous les jours pour tout ce qui m'importe
et je n'ai pas peur de laisser mes
bougies [musique]
hey
[musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime ça je ne vais pas
pleurer tu me manques je ne vais pas
pleurer je t'aime je  je ne vais pas
pleurer je t'ai tué je ne vais pas
[Musique]
tu me manques je ne vais pas
pleurer
[Musique]
bleu